each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so it's a great pleasure to introduce
Karthik pada Merriman Karthik is a
finishing his PhD at the University of
Illinois in urbana-champaign under Ravi
I are currently work has been focused on
fault tolerance and as he's going to
talk about critical data so this is a
really interesting work in the context
of the hardware developments and as we
see into the future we're going to see
more and more unreliable components in
hardware and so we'll see Karthik is
going to talk about how we can deal with
those those issues as they surface up to
the software Thanks Thank You Ben well
it's a great pleasure to be here today
thank you all for coming to my talk so
before I want you to been talked a
little bit above me as men was saying i
come from a fault tolerance and security
background but during the course of my
PhD I've applied techniques from
compiler design computer architecture
and formal methods to design these kind
of fall tour and systems and what I'm
going to be talking about today is one
particular aspect of my dissertation
work and the work I've done here at
Microsoft on critical data protection
for reliability and security so my broad
motivation is to build trustworthy
systems as you all know trustworthy
systems are those that are both reliable
and secure so if you look at the kinds
of threats to building trust trustworthy
systems first you have software bugs
which caused the US economy 60 billion
dollars a year then you have hardware
errors now most of us think of hardware
is being inherently dependable but it
turns out as you shrink transistor sizes
they're becoming more and more
susceptible to things like cosmic
radiation and electric disturbances so
we really need to worry about these
errors also know from the security side
security attacks are no big money so
there are organized rings over there
that try to extort money from you by
attacking your security network and also
we're seeing a proliferation of devices
so it's really hard to come up with a
one-size-fits-all security technique so
as I was saying my motivation is to
provide protection from both errors and
attacks so if you look at the other
trend in computing today it's an ocean
of platforms now and I think of a plan
from I think of windows or unix but
there are also other kinds of platforms
that are coming up of there so one
example is smartphones and another
example of web browsers now these
platforms share two common features
first is there is very little isolation
among the components in these platforms
for functionality purposes and also they
are the economic value of the platform
really derives from it being extensible
so they allow third-party code to be
loaded in and supported in the same same
platform so all this means that a single
component can actually bring your entire
platform down if it's not written
correctly so you need both fault and
attack tolerance in order to ensure
dependability of these platforms so that
is the big picture now let me zoom in on
a particular class of errors and attack
that that most of you will be familiar
with and give a little preamble back so
i am going to be talking this talk about
memory corruption errors and attacks so
as you all know pointers I'm sorry
programs written in C++ or not memory
safe but that I mean a point i can write
to anywhere in memory and it's a fact
that many programs are still written
using these languages so to define a
memory corruption it's basically when a
memory location is either modified by a
point of writing outside its bounds
which is the classic buffer overflow or
by a point of writing to a freed object
which is your dangling pointer and how
big of a problem are these memory errors
and attacks well they account for
sixty-six percent of real world security
vulnerabilities according to third
database and the reason study found that
fifty-five percent of application
crashes in the field in fact come from
memory corruption so um let's yeah she
says an individual's on your slide at
previous life you say sixty-six percent
a real world security a chat session
events or is it vulnerabilities that are
found in sorry so that's a good point
right so these are vulnerabilities as
reported in the third database so as far
as I know no one has really gone and
profiled how many of these are attacked
versus how many of these are not but
these are all exploited in some way
or someone has formed an exploit Sunday
so yeah I really meant to say
vulnerabilities thank you for pointing
that out so let's look at existing
approaches to memory corruption so
there's one school of thought that
believes the rewriting in safe languages
is the way to go and rewriting code in
Java or C sharp and while this may in
fact be the way to go for certain
applications for the vast majority of
programs out there that are already
written in unsafe languages this
involves a considerable investment in
program our time and also even if you
did manage to write large portions of
your software in managed language you're
going to have performance critical
components that are probably still an
unsafe languages and you need to worry
about them the other school of thought
is that we can use static techniques to
do away with memory corruption or memory
errors and there's been some excellent
work here at Microsoft and Sal and ESP
that will allow you to check your coat
statically before you check before you
check it in the one major disadvantage
of these techniques is that they require
the entire code to be statically
analyzed before before you allow to
actually deploy and which may not be
possible if you don't have the source
code available to you and also as most
of your work with static analysis tools
know some of these have high rates of
false positives and we need to deal with
them now the other promising approach
here has been in terms of runtime
checking techniques and these are what I
call the all-or-nothing kind of
techniques which basically say so you
have dynamic checking which is going to
go and check every point all right at
runtime though at least those that you
couldn't remove statically and the
problem with these techniques is they
can have overheads as high as hundred
percent and an example of this would be
cred than CQ now the others sort of
could have thought from MIT says that
since okay so they make the observation
that many memory errors do not matter to
the program so when memory error occurs
simply pretend as though nothing
happened in continue execution and this
is the failure oblivious computing which
is which actually it turns out works
fine for programs like servers where the
error propagation is limited but in
reality programs do have that a
propagation and in my opinion is a very
dangerous
thing to do so in contrast to these
approaches my approach is more a data
centric approach what I call critical
data protection and it is based on this
observation that some application data
any application is more important than
other data so rather than treat all data
is equal we are going to focus on
protecting this subset of data check all
critical data so for a man to give you
complete examples from a reliability
point of view let's say her banking
application your bank account data is
clearly more important than say agreed
date or in a game in a computer game
your game player data may be more
important than say the state of the game
word and so on and similarly from a
security point of view you can think of
password variables or activity lord was
being things that you want to protect
from that occur and what I have taken
what I am going to present is a unified
approach to protect this critical data
selectively and make sure that it is
resilient from errors and security
attacks and in the process allows you to
realize significant performance and
resource benefits so to sort of show
graphically what I just said so imagine
this big yellow oval is application data
your little green oval is the critical
data so even if the rest of the data is
corrupted due to memory errors or
attacks you want to make sure that a
critical data is itself safe from
corruption and one advantage of this
technique is that you can actually
choose the critical data and
incrementally choose more data over time
so you can apply it on for legacy
systems and you can continuously tune it
based on the protection required the
other major advantage here as you as you
are as I will show you in the technique
is that you only need the code that
actually modifies a critical data you do
not need access to the rest of the code
that application that just right outside
this oven so what all this really bites
you in the end is that you can get local
reasoning about a modules critical data
independent of the other modules so you
as a developer can protect the data in
your module and and be certain that it
is free from corruption due to other
modules in your program and this is an
important goal I believe from
when you consider the trends in
computing I talked about to the rise of
emerging platforms and increases in
errors and attacks so before I launch
into some into my exact techniques let
me give you a big picture so I have
looked at the critical data protection
by lang in the course of multiple
systems I built both at the University
of Illinois as well as Microsoft
Research so as part of my PhD thesis I
came up with two techniques critical
variable recomputation and information
flow signatures in collaboration with
colleagues at Illinois so critical
variable recomputation actually deals
with protecting critical data from
Hardware transient errors so I'm not
going to be talking about that today but
if you have questions I'd be happy to to
to take them offline I'm going to talk
about information flow signatures which
is a technique to protect critical data
from memory corruption attacks I'm also
be going to be talking about samurai and
critical memory which is work at it here
at Microsoft in collaboration with bends
on and we not Grover and here we are
going to focus on protecting from memory
corruption errors and finally I also
work on holidays which is a system for
tolerating race conditions and this was
joined to work with dark orchid offski
been John and Rahul nakba so the other
way to sort of categorize these
techniques is what I have looked at in
my dissertation is mostly we known error
and attack detection whereas what I have
looked at here is mostly on detection as
well as collection so as i said i'm
going to talk talk mostly about ifs and
samra so before yeah I'm sorry chef
English rum although investigate runs
from prevents hours or attacks against
as an application itself such a invite
compromise a system where other one
built a nest your critical information
you want or tanks against them so are
you talking about like operating system
rootkits and virtual machine behavior is
another vacation as very shy and
compromise ants and just get your own
the machine so yeah so right now I do
not deal with those kind of resent
attack but i'll come back to your
question when i talk about my future
work but i'll discuss on what we can
address that thank you
alright so in addition to the critical
data protection or let me sort of give
you one slight introduction to what my
dissertation research is about and then
I will focus on liquidator time so I
have been broadly involved in building
efficient error and attack detectors for
applications so by this we want to be
able to detect errors and attacks before
they cause problems in the system so i
built a unified compiler framework for
static analysis and implemented this in
software and reconfigurable hardware in
collaboration with my colleagues and
this has actually been prototype as part
of a trusted iliac project for the
trusted iliac project at Illinois which
aims to build reliable and secure
systems using reconfigurable hardware
and software I have also worked on
dynamic analysis techniques and
dependability evaluation in particular I
have looked at how to derive detectors
using machine learning techniques and
build probabilistic models of coverage
evaluation and finally a reason
direction that I've been luring is the
use of formal techniques for verifying
detectors so I looked at both model
checking as well as they are improving
techniques so I'm not going to be
talking about these other techniques in
detail but if you have questions we can
be happy to talk to you about them
offline so in this talk I am going to be
talking about two techniques I am
motivated and motivated the problem and
explain the approach so the first
technique I am going to talk about is
this notion of information flow
signatures for security and this is
joint work with my colleagues at the
University of Illinois so the IFS
technique is is based on the observation
that the results of memory corruption
are really undefined according to the C
C++ language semantics now this is not a
new observation but what we what what we
really observe is that the runtime is
not gonna is not enforcing this
isolation among objects but the language
semantics makes the result of memory
corruption and defined and it is
precisely this that attackers exploit in
violation of the language semantics to
overwrite data and application now what
is innovative of what we have done here
is to selectively enforce the source
level properties of rights to this
critical data at runtime so I will
explain that in a minute
but there are a couple of things part of
that so first it seems we are explored
since we are enforcing source level
properties we do not get false positives
because they are always on the source
code secondly we can ensure that the
critical data integrity is preserved
even if other data is compromised will
attack and this also allows us to get
local reasoning and incremental
protection as security okay so let me
look at a look at the class of attacks
that we want to consider here so
certainly we want to consider memory
corruption attacks like before flows and
format strings we also consider insider
attacks where you have parts of your
code that are in and of itself malicious
so malicious libraries or 3rd party
plugins a part of my attack model I am
also going to consider a program binary
modifications after it has been through
our compilation process and the real
sort of insight here is that we can
enforce this I this information flow
signatures using compiler and runtime so
at compile time I am going to extract
the backward dependencies of critical
data of critical variables in the
program and convert it to the
information flow signatures and at
runtime i am going to recalculate the
information flow signatures based on the
observed rights of the critical
variables and compare the runtime
signature with the derive signature a
mismatch indicates a memory corruption
attack and the program will be halted
yes like a list of principle variables
okay that's a good question I will come
back to the later but for now what we
have done is we have looked at these
programs and picked out variables that
we think would be ripe targets from an
attack meaning by attacking those
variables you can actually gain control
of the application in certain ways now
that being said I am actually not going
to talk about okay so here I am I should
clarify i'm considering database
corruption meaning you cut up some data
and try to get control of the
application so i am not going to talk
about things like return address
corruption etcetera so those are there
are techniques out there that already
deal with with with protecting control
data what I am focusing on is this no
one control data which is important to
the application thanks all right so let
me give a conceptual example
all of the information flow signatures
approach and this is from the openssh
program I just want to say that here I
this example is only to illustrate the
concept I will this not the way we
really implemented so here I have number
the lines in this program so what this
function does is exception user password
in the earth context and then the system
password and then it's going to return
the value of authenticated if these
passwords match so it's going to return
one if the passwords match otherwise
it's going to say the authentication
failed so here authenticated let's say
is a critical variable you want to
protect because if I attack a manages to
somehow influence that value then you
could he or she could authenticate
themselves wrongly to the system so what
we are going to do is is to encode the
entire backward dependencies of the
authenticated variable in this program
and that's actually the signature that
you see that it's the actual encoding is
not important i'll show you how we do it
but for now what we do is we go back
across eat for each data dependence of
the of the state program statement six
and then go do it in this fashion now
let's say there was a hypothetical
format string attack at line five here
and for those of you were you know for
listening attack basically I allows a
user that you use a provided buffer to
be used as a fall at shrink so there are
smart tricks and attack that would play
to write anywhere in memory using this
attack although this is hypothetical and
sense that SS it doesn't have this
attack actually another application we
looked at ftp has a very similar attack
in the authentication function so it's
not that hard and so on is not that
hypothetical that's it so let's say from
this format string attack you wrote to
the value of encrypted password variable
which is being used here so you see the
observed runtime signature for the
further variable authenticated actually
changes because of the right to to the
to the backward slice so you see we if
we had a technique to actually monitor
this and compare it compare all the
rights to the authenticated variable we
would notice this mismatch in the
signatures
and we could halt the program and take
corrective action so the real key here
is that by encoding the entire backward
slice you can you can detect any memory
attack that attempts to influence a
critical variable not just the one that
writes directly there and that's
actually one of the key elements here
that we need to go back the whole range
because remember we are protecting
selective variable so but so let me
present the overall algorithm then I
will go into details so we first do
static analysis to extract the
interprocedural backwards line so
critical variables and here we identify
the instructions in the backward slice
as trusted instructions and the data
objects is the top of the slice as
trusted data we also identify the target
data objects for these trusted
instructions all this is done at compile
time and run time I am actually going to
use a combination of hardware and
software then force the backward slice
of the critical data so we break it into
two levels of checks level one check
which is implemented in hardware and
level to check which is implemented in
software and we will halt the program of
either of these two checks is violated
so let me explain intuition behind both
of these runtime checks then I will
explain the how we actually enforce them
so as I was saying all the instructions
in the backward slice of the critical
variables are labeled as trusted
instructions by the compiler so what the
level one check is going to ensure is
that only the set of trusted
instructions can actually influence the
value of critical variables at one so
that's the invariant it reserves and you
need to check this for all instructions
in the program now remember you you may
not really have control over all the
third party code that gets loaded here
so you have to really enforce this check
and hardware to make sure that whenever
an instruction is executed and you it's
going to influence the critical variable
you have to make sure that it's trusted
so in particular there is an untrusted
instruction that tries to influence it
this will be prevented yes in a question
I'm talking about right so I am focused
on critical data integrity
confidentiality is another issue that i
haven't ok so the level so at this point
may be thinking what ok we have enforced
that trusted instructions right to
critical variables what else do we need
to do so we have this level to check
which makes sure that only eats trusted
that eats trusted instruction only
influence it's critical variable and no
other for aggravated so it's sort of
like trusting the trusted instructions
but making sure that they're doing the
right thing and what we enforce here is
that each trusted instruction rights
only two it's allowed target objects as
determined by the compiler and the key
inside here is that you only need to
check this for the trusted instructions
in the program so you can actually do a
much slower software check because you
have done the power of filtering trusted
instructions and hardware you can
actually check whether the trust of
instructions writing to its critical
data using software only we had a
question so I heard about this point
analysis to basically tell you what's
instruction can write for once of memory
location is when yours you you can't
mission both the traffic is an
information flow missing in two tracks
were right i can write to a then be read
and write of being right and that's kind
of the information of line here you are
talking about this very similar to the
point or not comparable but good great
thank you so what we are really doing is
we are enforcing the pointer analysis
discovered properties but for the
critical data alone at runtime so i am
in fact going to use compiler base
pointer analysis to extract which rights
to wear on this backward dependence
chain but the royalty here is to make
sure that only these things right at one
time and only for the critical data
alright so as i said if a trusted
instruction tries to write to a
different critical variable we will
actually prevented from doing so now
this serves to protect two kinds of
attacks so one is if you are trusted
instruction somehow depends on user
input so let's say you you use an
array index on that and you're using
that to write to a critical variable now
you trust that that instruction rights
to a of I which is varying index you do
not trust that it right so maybe a
password variable so we want to so the
compiler analysis will actually contain
where the trestle instruction rights and
you want to make sure it's obit the
other thing it protects is remember
there are untrusted third-party modules
here so you want to make sure that
trusted instructions that don't comment
right to your own data here so let me
sort of walk you through the compilation
process then i'll show you how these
checks implemented at one time so this
is a very abstract block diagram i'm not
going to go into their details we have
questions I'd be happy to get into that
so we start with the trusted modules and
the annotations for critical data so
grammar you would write these
validations now we have a trusted
compilation part for these trusted
modules that allows us to generate the
object code of the trusted module and
also to generate the cluster
instructions and they target for this
module so the Assumption I'm making here
is that only the trusted module can
legitimately or if I critical data no
other module has any business modifying
critical data so the object code of
untrusted modules can be directly linked
with the object over the trusted module
to get this this composite module so
notice we do not need the source code
source code for this unter said module
now we use the linker I mean after the
linker has gone through this we go and
create a final executable in which we
have actually digitally signed the
critical data on the trusted
instructions so the trusted compiler
makes sure that that the critical data
on tercel instruction for this module a
part of the final executable you know in
a in a verifiable fashion now I'm sorry
about the truncation of my title Val
that should have said ifs level one
check implementation and we implement
this in hardware so there are three key
points here so in hardware we associate
a special bit with every instruction and
data item so we call this the trusted
bit now at load time program load time
we assume there's a trusted loader which
verifies the integrity of the trusted
instructions of the data that
being signed by the compiler and this
trusted loader then goes and initializes
the critical data as well as the trusted
bits of the instructions or data in the
slice so this is at starting time so you
get the initial data elements as well as
initial as well as a trusted
instructions now at run time you will
propagate the trusted mess of a data
operand by using the following rules so
trusted nurse of an instructions
destination is another instructions
destinations trusted if one only if the
instruction is trusted and it's all its
operands interested so some of you may
notice the similarity here to tainted
pneus but the key difference is tainted
nas's going to track who is not trusted
and well it's going to track where you
come from where user very good user
input but as what trust earnest is doing
is saying there's a small subset of your
trusted instruction and I want to track
you know which data and which
instructions are going to be used 10 and
hence we can actually avoid some of the
some of the false positives issues with
tainted respect so this is the action
table too there is a table of action
that need to be taken for each of these
cases I won't walk through this whole
table but just wanted to give you the
high level inside so whenever anything
untrusted rights to critical data you
should raise an alarm okay because of
course you don't trust it so why is it
writing there now when when it's when it
is untrusted when the instruction is
untrusted and it is right then it writes
a non critical data it's fine you can
just allow this to proceed because this
is what the majority of the instructions
are going to be doing when your
instruction is trusted but its operands
are not trusted the and it tries to
write to non critical data we will raise
an alarm because the fact that the
instruction is trusted means that it at
some future point potentially going to
go and likely to influence a critical
data so you want to sort of cut the
propagation early on in the chain and
you raise an alarm there if however both
the instruction and its operands are
trusted you allow it in level one check
but now you pass it to the software
check which is going to make sure that
the instruction is really doing what
it's supposed to be doing and that's
what this is
to check implementation software so
whenever you will see a trusted
instruction right to critical and
non-critical data you get a trap from
the 11 one check and when I say trap
here does not mean like an OS level trap
it just means like a high speed trap
handler that's part of your application
and when you get this you get the pc and
the destination address so the first
thing you do is to look up the allowed
target objects for this trusted program
counter instruction in a special table
which we call the instruction to all out
data table and this is initialized in
order now starting from that we look up
the address range of the allowed target
objects based on object type so there
are three kinds of objects we consider
local variables which have a relativity
which have a relative offset from the
base pointer global variables with the
heap address and heap objects that are
identified by the range and then we
compare the destination that is that you
got from the trap with the address that
you get from here and we raise alarm if
there is no match now notice that for
local variables and global global
variables the addresses in this table
are fix it they can be initialized by
the compiler however for memory for heap
objects we need to be able to allow
malik's and freeze to manipulate the
data there so we assume there is a
trusted malik call which is also
protected with our technique and the
trusted malik is alone allowed to write
to this table containing heap data got a
question well if you choose the
two-level tracking I mean when the
hardware level courses aren't you and
shame in practice right well that's it
I'm glad that's all right ok you well ok
let me address the second question in a
minute but first let me address your
first question which is why we have this
two levels of checking so first is we
want to use hardware to do the slow
operation in terms of checking which
instructions trusted or not it needs to
be done for every instruction and then
sort of filter out easily the ones that
we need to do the more complicated
checking for and hardware if you look at
the rules for trust propagation those
are really simple so you can build
hardware to propagate that pretty
efficiently as i will show now results
now for software check
we are really going through this whole
algorithm and checking multiple
instruction ranges etc now in theory we
could we could design a efficient
hardware to do that but as I will show
the overhead of this software checking
is actually very small compared to the
overhead of compared to the overall
overhead of the application so that's
why we chose to do the more complex
second software but we do the sort of
easier one but that needs to be done on
every instruction in hardware now let me
address your second question actually an
end because you asking about how
practical this approaches but but I just
say this we are adding one in one bit
for every instruction and data operating
in our system and I don't think I mean
the hardware changes are actually pretty
minimal though it can go into that yeah
it's possible to leverage work coming
vinson in hardware for change in this is
the way that that's a great point so
there has been a lot of work like raksha
and no Chennithala publishers so they
they associate a tainted bit with every
item and then track it as it moves
through so definitely we can leave a
leverage those were those those
techniques and in fact we even explored
using our technique as a policy to one
of those other daintiness tracking
technique but since you bring up the
promotion of tainted as there is a
difference under since the Internet's
can have false positives because you
know user data may be allowed to write
to these variables but as our technique
does not have any false positives at
least for correct see code so if you
give us the code and user data can
legitimately go and influence some some
data and that's touch that's something
that they are in the code we will
actually faithfully enforce that so we
are more like a partial I say we enforce
the source level properties of the
critical area okay so let me sort of tie
decent together with the openssh example
then I'll present the result so this is
the same example that I showed you at
the beginning of the of this technique
so you have the authenticated critical
variable now the compiler marks the
instructions in the backward slice so
this would actually be PC program
counter addresses but for convenience
are just show on them as program
statements right it would mark the
instructions of backward slices trusted
instruction will also mark the
instructions of the top as trusted data
now due to space constraints on the
slide I have shown the instructions that
are passed into the function as trusted
data but in reality this would be an
inter procedural slice and notice that
the S printf which is the format string
and attack and another instruction are
actually interested now rather than go
through this we as I told you I have we
isolate the targets of each transfer
instruction and at runtime using the
rules for trust in his propagation you
would actually propagate the trust admit
to all these targets all the way down to
authenticate so you see build up this
whole chain of toss now let us assume I
just removed a portion of the graph to
show you something now so let us assume
there was an untrusted instruction that
came and tried to write to this shadow
pw variable so in the process it is
trying to manipulate it to its advantage
and authenticate to the attacker so when
an untrusted instruction rights to this
variable is going to create clear the
trust redness bit of that variable now
according to the rules of level one
check when I actually read from
untrusted data and trusted instruction
reads from untrusted data that's a no-no
so you raise an alarm and it prevented
in hardware now let's say you have a
slightly smarter attacker or a different
module which is going to it's still
trusted but it's supposed to be writing
to some other data but you have somehow
manipulated it through user input to to
go and try to write to this pw variable
now this would be passed by the level
one check but it will be prevented by
the level to check because this would
not be the allowed target for this
variable now at this point I should
mention that whatever guarantees we
enforce are only as good or as
determined by the compilers point
analysis so we need pretty precise
compilers point analysis for this module
in order to make sure the guarantees are
typed okay so we tried this or we apply
this technique to three real server
programs so openssh w FTP and null HTTP
now in each of these programs be
protected a specific module that was
important for security critical
functionality
so in openssh we protected the
authentication module because you don't
want that occurred to miss authenticate
themselves in ftp we protected a logging
module so whenever an attacker does some
whenever user does some action the
action is lon so an attacker may try to
attract this module in and and erase
their traces essentially and a null HTTP
program we actually protected the web
page serving module so when you when you
request a web page it goes and gets a
file which is distributed to you so as
an attacker you can try to mess with
that file and you know serve your own
web pages perhaps so each of these we we
identified critical variables based on
our understanding of the code which are
places where the attacker would want to
go and try two variables the attacker
would try to corrupt in order to get get
their ends matter and we found that we
could by protecting these variables we
had only I'm sorry that so we had only
few trusted instructions for each of
these variables so even if the rest of
the code was still unprotected you would
still make sure that these variables
were being protected in this module and
as you can see the total number of
instructions in each of these programs
is pretty large though the modules
themselves are free self-contained and
the trusted instructions are even fewer
so the Assumption here is that by
protecting a small portion of this whole
data you can make sure that the attacker
does not manage to violate any of your
any of the functionality you want to
protect and we have implemented this in
the impact compiler or the open impact
compiler using static analysis for
extracting the information flow
signature the level one check you have
actually implemented it on a real
process early on three processor from
case law research and we had to make
small modifications to the pipeline
stages but they were they could be
mostly done in parallel with the
pipeline the operations I mean and then
we actually went and synthesize this on
an FPGA with xilinx vertex 2 pro so this
was the done by my colleague who who
modified the very loud model with the
rules that I had come up with and then
we found
the performance overhead for this
technique when you do level one check
and hardware is ten percent now for
those of you who may not be familiar
with Hardware ten percent may seem like
a number that I be seeing this from so
it turns out that whenever you add a
wire to your processor or any signal
you're going to have to slow down the
clock because you're not going to be
able to clock it at the same rate as
before you there are longer wire delays
so we actually saw that when we added
some of our structures we were seeing
this ten percent increase in in clock
cycle time and let me remind you that
this overhead we would not have seen in
simulation in fact we did our grain
based simulation initially and our
overheads were almost zero percent but
so whenever you see techniques I mean
simulation is a great tool I believe
it's great for prototyping but whenever
you see techniques they report very low
overheads security techniques especially
with that report very low hardware
overheads and simulation you need to ask
you know what would this really be in
the context of a processor so Leanne
three what is that so this is far is a
so what we do is we compiled to the Leon
3 back end with our modifications so we
actually have makeup modifications off
the critic so we we pull out wires from
the pipeline stages and then we can't
figure our checks in a checking module
that's part of them so I I didn't
present the hardware architecture here
but I be happy to it it's real hard by
executing fpga runs slower than the
process so that's a good point so we
actually synthesize this at the highest
frequency available for the Leon plaster
so I mean of course we don't have access
to a fab otherwise you know but but I
mean you know from a academic project
point of view this was probably the best
we could do in terms of trying to build
this change by having three bills well
actually what we do is we pull out wires
from the pipeline stages so we don't so
we have a shadow register file so there
is this turrble so we don't actually add
it to the main register file we keep
everything shadowed and then when you do
a page fault we bring in a bit
mask for the for the trusted
instructions on the page so we try not
to change the existing memory layout and
register layout in the processor discuss
the details but that's more like an
implementation I'm sorry tempest Sanders
in songwriting if you're using the same
thing that this time its use my friends
mhm well okay I mean we can probably
talk more about this offline but our
synthesis frequencies where you are
talking about Raksha right so our
synthesis frequencies are actually much
higher than theirs so we synthesized at
the recommended clock speed so that
could be a reason why we are seeing
these Eastern clock cycle alright so and
then we implemented the level two as a
software library and we found that the
performance overhead was pretty
negligible because as we saw the trusted
instructions were only a small fraction
of the overall program code so in
summary for the ifs technique and one
you have sorry yeah you see one person
since I really depends on some of the
incredible variables you are tracking
right and your cash cash is a while two
variables you're tracking that's the one
percent so that's right so what we do is
we feel we go to the code and look at
the variables that we think an attacker
could exploit now you if I'm not saying
that the one percent is sort of the sand
at that so if you protect more data
you're going to see an increase in that
but at least it's configurable based on
how much data you want to protect in
your application so you decide how much
price you want to pay and they're
protected accordingly now the ten
percent however is the fixed cost that
you pay because of the extra hardware
that you need to allow you to do this
kind of configuration where goes to xbox
one person we have five to ten so for
these modules they actually are the
authentication module logging module are
actually occupying like two or three
percent of the whole program execution
time so you know they are not on the
performance critical path in this case
now
and I believe that for many programs the
Rio league security critical or
reliability critical functionality is
not going to be necessarily
underperformance limiting path now when
I talk about samurai I'll actually show
you an example where an assumption was
wrong we actually found a certain case
where it was on the performance critical
path but I would I will come to that
Thanks ok so the IFS technique ensures
that critical variables are not
compromised by memory corruption attacks
the security critical variables are
identified by the programmer and ifs is
extracted automatically using the impact
compiler and we have implemented this as
a two-level checking scheme using
hardware and software and in terms of
implementation we have an FPGA hardware
real processor the be synthesized on an
FPGA and we have various server
applications that we have let me try it
on this the performance overhead we
observed was in hardware was about ten
percent and the software overhead that
we observed for the applications and
critical variables that we protected was
negligible so before I move on to the
next the next project here let me sort
of give you a big picture slide on the
other aspects of what I've been doing so
I built this compiler framework for
security and reliability and the common
aspects in this framework are as follows
so first we identify the critical
variables or memory objects and their
locations in the program then from this
using static analysis we extract the
backward slices of the backward
dependencies of the critical variables
and finally we convert the backward
slices to runtime checks to ensure the
integrity is a critical data so what I
showed you was one half of the story
which is the security side where you
choose variables that are important for
application integrity and then generate
checks to verify that the value is
produced by legitimate instructions the
other half of my dissertation actually
deals with the reliability side of
things where you choose the variables
are important for application recovery
but you generate correctness checks for
these values but actually recomputing
them using the slices so that we
recompute we come up with concise
checking expressions for these critical
variables and use FPGA hardware to
recompute them as the application excuse
I am NOT going to talk about that
today but I'd be happy to take questions
after the talk so let me know move on to
the second project that I am going to
talk about this is samurai or critical
memory for reliability of protection
from memory corruption errors and this
is joint work with Ben zone and Vinod
Grover and I started this work when I
was an intern here but continued it
driving back to Illinois so the idea
behind critical memory is as follows so
we want to we want an abstract model or
memory model for reasoning about
critical data so you want to be able to
protect your critical data as well as be
able to reason about it so that you can
you get some guarantees in terms of what
production you get so the key here is
that you need to mark the critical data
using this keyword similar to a constant
qualifier and the the programmer or
other the compiler has to identify where
this critical data is read from as well
as to tend to so when you read from it
we use a special operation called a
critical node and when you write to it
use a special operation call a critical
store so let me sort of give you a a one
slight tutorial on what this memory
model is going to do then I will show
you how we really use it so as the
critical memory so essentially the idea
here is that you slip away or under
normal memory okay so you have normal
memory on top and underneath you have
critical memory did you have a question
so this layer parallels normal memory
and has special operations so let's
start with the critical store operation
which is C store which is storing the
value 5x so normal memory is shown in
green and critical memory shown in blue
so the critical store is going to update
both the normal memory as well as
critical memory locations then you have
a regular stone these are unmodified
stores in a program and they are going
to write to normal memory as before but
they don't change the critical values so
at this point when you do a store we
have x equals 2 and in normal memory in
x equals 5 in critical memory then when
you try to do a normal load you are
simply going to read the value in normal
memory so you're going to read the value
to and but you're not going to see the
value
in critical memory finally you do a
critical node at this point you are
going to go to the value in critical
memory and return five but you can but
you have a choice you you you notice
there's a discrepancy between the value
normal memory in critical memory and you
can either correct this discrepancy as
we will do but you can also think of
having a debugging debugging model where
you trap on this mismatch or
alternatively you can just ignore normal
memory and say it's not my problem i
have my data anyway so okay that was all
good memory models who is this really
going to help me protect from memory
errors so let's say that this is the
same code that i showed you too sly
devil is a critical in balance and let's
say there is a memory error here where
you are going to try to write to buffer
of 15 you're going to increment it by
200 now because of the way the compiler
is laid out objects here buffer of 15 is
actually going to point to balance
assume this so no when I try to so so
let's see what let me walk you through
the steps here and show you what happens
to the data so when you see the critical
in balance that gets translated to this
map critical command map critical
instruction which is going to make sure
that your balance has a copy in normal
memory as well as in critical memory
then you see balance equal to 100 this
is the compiler can recognize that this
is just an update to balance so it is
going to you replace or it's going to
use a critical store instruction to
write to the value of balance and it's
going to update the value in both normal
memory and critical memory with hundred
now let's say you try to do a load so
this is when you do buffer of 15 plus
equals 200 so at this point the compiler
is going to assume that all objects are
infinitely far apart in memory so it
does not reason about memory before most
lowes so it is going to translate the
reference to buffer of 15 to a regular
load instruction and it is going to
return hundred and more importantly is
going to translate the store that to
regular store which is going to actually
implement the value in
memory by 200 so you see at this point
you have a discrepancy between the value
and critical memory in a value in normal
memory now you go back to this load here
when you do balance less than min again
this is a load from a critical data
location so it gets translated to
critical load and in the semantics that
we have implemented we actually notice
this this creeper seein corrected so a
couple of things to take away from this
slide so you see you can actually
selectively protect the data critical
data from memory errors because from the
point of view of this piece of code it's
seeing a consistent value yes I already
generate targeted assignments 15 use the
address announced right so thank you
thank you so what we do here in this
example is that when you look at the
compiler static analysis buffer or 15
and buffer and balance are two distinct
objects right so buffer in this case is
not critical so it's going to so
whenever you have a reference critical
data is going to generate critical loads
and pinnacle stores for normal data is
just going to be normal notice those now
that being said we haven't actually
implemented static analysis based system
to annotate this so for now the
implementation I will describe a
actually manually annotated so we but
you can think of having compiler support
where you when you reference critical
data you automatically generate critical
loads and critical stores don't
understand how why does he say tim was a
sign one ampere simple and then you are
in your app store or 1500 could do 15
elements pause there but it still be a
normal store because it doesn't know
that that store is in fact to critical
memory it has to be balanced if you
happen to be balancing skills
Plus is exactly right yeah sorry I
should have said that yeah so so so in
this case the the way the runtime places
the objects is this fashion but after
the compilers point of view these are
all separate object yeah what day for
like a one instruction in the source
code one line in the source code is that
say you cannot decide to turn static
analysis it will be a critical store on
synonymous oh man right so there are two
ways to hundreds that so first is if
your pointer analysis comes back and
says I don't know where this thing is
going to write so you can give a warning
to the user at that point and it was a
developer and then you can try to make
them so when you try to use white starts
this event is likely to happen so you
can sort of use annotations to guide the
compiler at that point but you only need
to do this for the critical data the
other way to think about it rest you can
conservatively mark stores as critical
as long as you're not doing too many of
them you are still okay because critical
stores can try to normal data just fine
it's just the data you know one the
other way no wanted to go another way so
being conservative is an option but if
you really wanted to get the guarantees
then you would have to be have precise
analysis at Point oh yeah tell you need
to call operation so that otherwise the
credit loans are allowed to write a
special personal so you in such an
implementation truck Factory so you
could have such a such a implementation
where you if you can't tell you simply
do normal stuff but then at runtime
you're going to see a discrepancy
between the value normal memory in
critical memory so you were proactively
collected when that was not the intended
effect in the code so I mean so it
depends on which side you want to L
whether you want to err on the side of
caution whether you want to err on the
side of you know it doesn't matter if
occasionally you miss all right but i
believe it's better to err on the side
of caution here and and give a message
to the programmer saying look you know I
can't really tell what the value writing
to can you make your intentions more
explicit
right so the runtime check here is only
going to tell whether you're going to
write the critical data or not right i
mean because you get the destination and
then going to tell that one time whether
it is writing to critical data or not
you still do not know statically where
it was going to write to mean because
you don't know if it was allowed to
write to critical data or whether it was
not so here's the way to think about it
you get an address at one time right so
if it happens to be a critical address
right and it's a critical I mean if it
happens to be a critical address you
don't know at that point whether the
store there was in fact supposed to
write to that critical address or not
right but you don't know whether the
store that the store instruction was a
critical store right because if you
don't mark it if you just marked it as a
normal store then you reason that it's
not supposed to write to the critical
data so you just you either create a
certain store instruction or you just
check if else yeah they said the first
works in fact in fact we do they felt
which is why you can conservatively mark
stores as critical in your code so you
can you can mark a store that never
writes a critical memory as critical and
you'll be fine the program still works
the problem comes when you miss stores
that we're going to write a critical
memory but if forgot to mark them I
don't know if I'm being okay yeah but
I'd be happy to know Rover this yeah i
feel like i miss my father's if you have
this critical balance my father's story
normal memory at all okay so i have not
told you so far about you know the
actual layout of memory but one of our
assumptions is that as far as possible
you don't want to change the format of
pointers to memory etc so you you want
this critical balance to to be sort of
manipulated in the regular program using
a regular pointer now you can think of
storing this and say a separate address
space for example and it's certainly
possible that's an implementation choice
at this point all I'm saying this
critical memory gives you this notion of
separation between critical data and
normal data and normal memory and allows
you to read about it when I come to
samurai which is the implementation of
this I will actually use replication to
store multiple copies of balance
so you do not need to go to the supper
in terms of space in the same address
space you store it sky in different
scattered locations and then you do a
majority voting to make sure that the
value of balance is not connected so now
there's one more question here what
happens if you what happens when you had
untrusted third party module so let's
consider the same code as before so you
had buffer and you had this update of
balance let's say at this point you call
this this function which is untrusted
and you don't have the code of this
function but you you could were to call
it with x and y now when the untrusted
function is going to read the value of
balance and it's also going to do an
update of balance let's see so it's the
same cases before now you have a
discrepancy between the value in normal
memory and critical memory when this
function returns at this point you as an
implementer of the caller code has a
choice you can say I don't trust that
guy to mess with my value of talents so
I am simply going to ignore him and go
ahead with my computation so you can you
don't have to do anything at this point
and your value of balance is preserved
but what have you actually sort of
trusted that code update balance as long
as it didn't write some outrageous value
in that let's say so at this point you
can check the value of balance in the
crawler function and then you can do an
explicit promote operation which you're
saying look I trust this code to update
balance because I have just checked they
did what you're going to do so now I am
going to copy the value of balance from
normal memory to critical memory now
note to note a couple of things again
here is that if this function let's say
crashes does not return you're fine
because a critical data still or if you
know it it messed up the value of
balance it's fine because you're going
to check it also the function is only
allowed so it only the modifications
made to balance are actually promoted so
if it corrupted something else like say
a password here you you don't promote it
and hence the mod the corruption simply
disappears so for the point of view of
this
or you can almost walk through this and
reason about what gets changed back so
this is the local reasoning aspect that
I alluded to that you get from using
this model so so far I've told you all
this nice memory model where you have
this hidden layer right and then you
have special instructions and it may
seem like what have been describing is a
hardware implementation but actually we
can implement this in software and this
is what we did which is the case of
samurai so we built a memory manager to
protect critical data critical heap data
and applications and here the inside is
as follows so when you have an object in
memory we are going to keep two replicas
of that object that are randomly
scattered through memory okay and they
are going to reflect the contents of
this object at any point now also we
keep pointers to these replicas in the
metadata of the main object so now when
you do a critical store it is going to
go and update all the tree replicas by
following these metadata pointers and
it's going to make sure that the changes
are reflected now let's say you did a
regular store operation at this point
this could be this is your memory error
so you could overwrite any of these
replicas here I've shown you overriding
the main object but it could be any of
these replicas but then you do a
critical load you're going to do a
majority vote of these three replicas at
that point you can notice you will
notice the inconsistency and you can
optionally go and repair and in fact we
repair on this mismatch so you may be
wondering what happens if this metadata
is corrupted because this point is a
stray one you can write whenever it
wants so we also take care to protect
the metadata a check sums and store it
in a special backup mechanism so the way
to think about it in terms of critical
memory is the critical memory state is
God by the majority of the state of the
replicas and I are going to go into the
implementation details of samurai here
but if you have questions I'd be happy
to answer them to rocky
thank you so are they okay so when we
talk about critical memory we have just
one copy right and we assume that some
of you couldn't write to that now when
you talk about the heap as a whole
pointers are writing where ever they
want right essentially so we can't
really be assured that one of the other
copy that we had in critical memory
doesn't get corrupted so we actually
split it into two and so that we can
take the majority of three to get this
data so we do not have any guarantees
about what gets corrupted and what
doesn't so we have to have three in
order to be able to detect the
corruption did I answer the question
alright so to evaluate samurai we have
an automated Phoenix pass to instrument
loads in source in the code and also a
runtime library for allocation and
de-allocation of critical data we
protected critical data and applications
mostly from the spec sweet programs we
chose data that is crucial for recovery
from program failures and we evaluated
the performance been fermenting loads
and stores and we also evaluated how
dependable this is were actually
performing fault injection experiments
in order to to to explore its utility
even further we protected critical data
in libraries like you took a memory
allocator where we protected the heap
metadata and we took an STL list class
where we protected the backbones in this
structure and i'm going to show you the
results for these so the performance
overhead with samurai we chose five
applications i won't go into how we
chose the critical data here but if you
have questions all means ask me so you
see that so the yellow golden bar is the
baseline and the blue bar is samurai so
you see the slow down for four of our
five applications is within ten percent
which is good where the bad news is that
for this application gzip our overhead
was almost as 3x and this is the
question that you asked earlier what if
we actually chose critical data that was
being intensely used so that's what
happened here we're in gzip this we
protected the hoffman decompression
tables because we figured if there was
an error resume you are going to mess up
the whole downstream decompression so it
turns out that those are precisely
on the the most performance critical
element in Jesus there's even an faq of
that that shows you how to optimize the
number of bits and these tables to get
efficiency so so you need to be careful
about what critical data you want to
choose because otherwise you could end
up in something like geez this was the
lesson we looked at least so but the
encouraging news here is there are
applications out there like these for
where you can protect a small amount of
data and with with reasonable over it so
just to make this concrete so in vp are
we protected the routing data structures
crafty you protected the chessboard in
parts of a protected the dictionary and
ray shade we protected the scene of
objects but I can go into why we chose
that later yes remove you have continued
into Rebecca's it will only mention one
round like hell so cheesy you let me use
a fullness forum so that's a good point
we haven't explored you know reducing
the number of replicas here but the but
the most okay so here's the real thing
the overhead comes because of the extra
metadata lookups and objects and then go
into the replicas so it's not so much
the actual loads or stores among the
replicas now we do have an optimization
of samurai where we check only one of
them we compare the replica with one and
then go to the third one only when there
is a mismatch but the but you need to be
careful that because if you don't ever
check the other one then you let it
accumulate headers over time so we
periodically swap pointers actually
there is a lot of you know
implementation tricks that I am not
really talking about here but yeah that
is one trick we can play to actually
reduce the overhead uploads so let me
present to you the memory allocator
result these are interesting so here
what we did is we took a standard
Kingsley allocator and we protected the
heap meta data that is stored by this
alligator so for as many of you know
there are security attack that just
focus on attacking the heap metadata and
try to take over a system so the real
insight here is that only your alligator
should be able to write to the negative
the application has no business going
and trying to be right to the heat
metadata so in this sense
education becomes the untrusted
third-party code and your allocators the
trusted entity so we we actually
instrumented the fields of the heap
metadata and compared it across a bunch
of heap intensive applications memory
allocation intensive applications and we
found that our average performance
overhead here was ten percent and the
worst case is 20 as you can see so the
to give some perspective this number
there are papers out there that actually
recommend separating the heat metadata
into separate process because it's so
worried about it being corrupted and
even with the with a whole lot of
implementation tricks their overheads
are fifty percent or more and whereas by
actually being selective and and
protecting the heap metadata in the same
phase of the object or overhead is only
about ten percent and I will go over
this quickly you also protected the stl
class where we predicted the backbone we
had to make some changes to the various
functions but these are like one-time
investments you make these changes and
after that we used this stl class in a
web server for maintaining information
about incoming connections for client
this is a multi-threaded web server and
we actually evaluated this across
multiple threads and connections and we
found that the maximum performance
overhead was nine percent here before a
sort of samurai let me give you a fault
injection results only one part of this
so this is our this is for one one
application which is vpr so what we did
was the corrupted heap objects with some
periodic periodic rate a heap critical
heap data and we measured how often the
application fails versus how often it
sucks see the graph on the right and
this side shows the results without
samurai and on the left it shows the
results with samurai and the golden bars
are successes yay we actually finished
and failures are the blue bars which are
you know application crashed or went
into an infinite loop and the so we see
first of all we see that you have a lot
more gold with samurai tan without okay
so that's good news oh I should have
said this earlier the x-axis
how how frequently we inject a fight so
every so when I say 100,000 is a fault
period that means every 100,000 memory
access i went and character like he
partly a critical he public so that is
however this one little red bar at the
top you know we're at a very aggressive
fault rate samurai actually detected
something was wrong but it wasn't able
to corrupt it because both are replicas
actually managed to get corrupted by the
same here but by two different as i'm
sorry now this problem could have been
avoided if you had more replicas and
paid more overhead of course but this
just shows that even though there are
cases where samurai may not be able to
correct your at least it detects it and
this is only happening at really
aggressive rates so we also did
injections into non critical data to
measure error propagation i am not going
to present those results today but i can
talk about them offline so in summary i
presented samurai critical memory
critical memory is your memory module it
is an abstract model reasonable critical
data and applications we have special
operations called critical loads in
stores and we allow them to interoperate
with untrusted third-party code samurai
is the software prototype of critical
memory it uses replication and forward
error correction and we have
demonstrated it on both applications and
libraries and found overheads of ten
percent or less i just want to say a
couple of things here our critical
memory is an abstraction which can be
implemented in many different ways so we
can even look at a hardware
implementation of critical memory and i
spent the summer of seven the other
explored a hardware implementation of
this with order mood fluent ben's on we
are also currently looking at other
kinds of software protection techniques
so other than replication and voting can
reduce smarter tricks and software to
ensure critical memory semantics
you mean just didn't call them or
introduce so I thought of koalas three
things in terms blue bus clashes in
correct output as well as Hank mostly
prevent against attacks programming so
I'm talking about correctness with
respect to the critical data so if it if
it completes correctly with respect to
the critical data that's all I'm in just
that experiment that's all I care about
now I had another set of experiments
they don't put up here when we looked at
the overall correctness of the
application as a whole so and a be
injected has every five not just in the
critical data and we wanted to see how
often it was a case of critical data was
not corrupted by those errors but I
don't put those numbers of all right let
me know sort of briefly touch upon
future work and then clue so there are
three directions that I would like to
explore starting from this critical data
paradigm so first and some of you
actually pointed this out that you
protect some data in application but how
do you know that is enough from a formal
point of view so can we do better and
I've given you a various experimental
anecdotal evidence but I have not so far
actually given you a formal foundation
to believe these are critical data is
the one you want to protect so what I
would what I would like to explore is
given a source program and specification
can be actually identify the critical
data automatically so with respect to
the specification can I say can you
figure out which data needs to be
protected and then implement those
checks on critical data and then pass
this through a compiler to to to protect
your program now you can do better how
do we know in fact that this protection
is sufficient because both errors and
attacks are going to happen at the
program on that level so here's where I
believe we can leverage formal
techniques so you can use a model
checker to take a set of errors or
attacks and then systematically explore
the space of those errors on the program
protector the checks and then see if
that's enough so you can get one of two
things you can say yeah the program is
correct or you can say sorry here is a
counter example and you can go
I can close the feedback loop with a
counterexample so I have actually
already build the model checker for
looking at errors as part of my PhD
diesels and this is the work so this
looks at hardware errors is the work at
alluded to earlier i am trying to extend
that to security attacks and but i
haven't even come close to looking at
how to close the feedback loop and look
at this so that's something i would like
to explore us or a future work so the
other direction i would like to explore
is this notion of secured compilation so
as i was saying earlier in the ifs
technique and even in samurai a lot of
the you haven't teased excuse me a lot
of the guarantees you get from the
technique depend on depend on the
efficacy of the compiler analysis
accuracy of the pointer analysis so we
we actually came up with qualitative
examples of which point analysis work
better to guide our choices but wouldn't
it be nice to have like a quantitative
model to actually choose the right kind
of point analysis for a given level of
protection this is what i would like to
explore so for this first we need to
understand we need to understand three
things what optimizations benefits
security what optimizations are
detrimental to security and other new
optimizations that we can explore to
protect this data selectively and what
makes us different from other point
analysis approaches is that we can
selectively tune the precision of the
analysis for critical data and programs
because remember we want to protect this
data this critical data so we can
actually come up with efficient ways to
to plot the pointers to that data more
accurately and the third direction that
i would like to explore is is using
multi-core processors to do checks and
multicores are here they presumably here
to stay so how can we leverage them to
you to get what we want so given a
program i plan to use automated
techniques to extract the critical data
checks the regular program is is
compiled on to a multi-core processor
here whereas the critical data checks
are compiled on to a special-purpose
compile using a special purpose compiler
to dedicated course and what i believe
is that as a number of course increases
you are not going to be able to liberate
all of them necessary
to get the performance you want so can
we have a few dedicated course for
checking reliability and security and
since we are only the only considering
critical data to be checked we can
actually share the dedicated course a
nun multiple main course so rather than
go and sort of no use all the available
course of performance then we dedicate a
small amount for reliability in security
and combined efficiently for those
course this is the direction that I
would like to explore and I am pretty
excited about so in conclusion I have
shown you or hope I've shown you that
critical data protection is a promising
new approach for containing a nurse and
attacks and the idea here is that we
will selectively protect a subset of
application data allow local reasoning
for application modules and also tune
the cost of protection based on your
application but this is only one step in
my broader research mission which is to
provide reliability and security the
existing applications with as low
overhead as possible so there is a huge
investment out there in C C++ code and
we really have to come up with these
kind of techniques to be able to protect
them so that and safeguard and
investment in these applications so too
for that I believe there are two things
that are necessary one is we need an
easy adoption path so we need to be able
to protect this applications
incrementally and start seeing the
benefits as and when we do the
production not wait till we protect
everything in order to see tangible
results and that brings me to the
conclusion of my talk thank you all for
your attention and happy to take
questions and if you have any
some right near bus or an attack but
somewhere somewhere else existing system
um yeah so right now we do not design
some of you did not design samurai to
protect from intelligent attacker in
fact fact I should have probably
emphasizes more somewhere I was designed
for accidental protection accidental
memory areas we have been exploring our
ways to make it more robust to attack us
so for example we can hide the location
of the critical data pointers to
replicas or we can encrypt them know
where it summarises Jenny provides
provide protection from for the critical
data from from that I give that occur if
the data is just you know regular
running the usual kind of tax now
however if you really wanted to protect
against a smart attacker who's trying to
game the system then we would have to
encrypt where we store the critical data
and the hope here is that attacker since
attacker cannot go and figure out where
these these replicas he or she will not
be able to collect them and hence we can
detect it and in fact this is one
direction that we are exploring as part
of this integrated framework for
configuring the level of protection
depending on the depending on our needs
and you know this is ongoing work good
bands on direction oh yeah that's a good
point too so it depends on what how much
power the attacker has so if you're
thinking of an attacker was all of you
know freezers application takes a
snapshot and then search us and then
uses various cryptographic or you know
entropy measures to look for the state I
you're right i mean we won't be able to
protect it so so that is you know
there's different levels of protection
from an attacker but if you really want
to protect against what you know yuba
attacker then i would recommend you use
ISS because now we even with samurai an
attacker can change the dependencies
right out where the critical data
derived from and get in the system
whereas with ifs we encode the whole
backward
three so we already have a way to
protect from yuba attacker so it's
question is the software support how
much closer can we get to have we want
to be thank you to focus on protecting
critical data but on the other hand we
have are facing control flow attacks and
you have done like in your first work
you have this in level one level two
protection but the sale is a can you
elaborate into what you are proposing
for protecting critical data for
protecting controls more attacks because
otherwise I think too and you make to
like to over hand to the chin were safe
system i miss occurring right well yeah
so as it stands know our system is more
focused for data protection now there's
no reason you couldn't use this for
protecting control data but you're going
to pay that kind of overhead now I would
I would actually say there are other
efficient techniques out there that do a
fairly good job protecting controlled
data so control flow integrity and
program shepherding are two such
techniques so after you employed the
techniques like this and protected
control data what are your attacker is
going to do they're going to come up to
these kind of variables in the program
which are going to give them action
benefit and actually Chen at all shuo
chen here show that such attacks are
practical even for current days
currently systems so I would argue that
to really liberate the benefits of our
system no you-you-you we go after the
kind of attack that would that would
that would be launched after you already
have controlled data protection in place
but that being said there is no reason
you couldn't apply it just is going to
pay you going to pay over here yes your
kind of solution now be applied arriving
for that's right that's just true which
address other critical data that's well
you could but that wouldn't be the most
efficient way to use there are more
efficient techniques out there so as I
said I'm not trying to compete with the
control data integrity control data
checking techniques there because I'm
saying let you know after we protect
those what what is left for an attacker
and that's why I'm
my focuses thank you all